laughs
up my fellow geeks zacky here back for
another fantastic video and as you can
see right behind me we've got a full
gaming setup and this is all thanks to
the folks at asus
this custom asus rig is powered by
nvidia's rtx 3070 ti a ryzen 5 5600 x
cpu and 16 gigabytes of ddr4 ram not to
mention we've got a slew of gaming
peripherals all courtesy of asus
now of course you guys are probably
asking yourselves hey zack why not a
3080 why not a 3090 and the thing is not
many of us can afford such a high end
gaming rig so we decided to go with a
more affordable option now of course the
game that we're gonna play is the most
hyped game that everyone has been
waiting for battlefield 2042 the open
beta version of course
now battlefield 2042 seems to be quite a
graphic intensive game so we can't wait
to see how the rtx 3070 ti is going to
perform i'm confident with the right
settings we should be able to get some
pretty decent frames so
let's get our boots on the ground
all right so we are logged in into
battlefield 2042 open beta of course
we've got the asus rig ready let's test
it out but before that let's get into
our options just to give you a glimpse
of what we're gonna be doing
4k resolution refresh rate at 60.
and the graphics quality is on ultra
now the rtx 3070 ti it's been more for
1080p gaming
a little bit on 4k
but nevertheless let's test it out and
see how it performs jumping to the game
oh i'm flying oh okay i'm flying the
carrier
looking good right now
it's 60 fps
let's dive down and take over
echo base
and see guys i'm a bailout
oh
oops
that was not supposed to happen
man this game is looking pretty good man
all right this is happening guys we are
dropping frames
like we are dropping flies
back down to 20
we're going even lower
and it looks like the frame rate it's
not looking so good for now now of
course we can expect some bugs because
this is the open beta now i'm going to
drop it down to medium and hopefully we
can get some stable frames in a hectic
environment i'm going to go back to
being a sniper
jumping into the headquarters
and
instantly
got a little bit extra pops that could
just be the game
i have to say a medium quality settings
at 4k it still looks pretty good puddles
and everything let's try and fire some
stuff and see whether we're going to
drop any frames
still stable like 60 frames per second
i'm enjoying this let's try
and have some fun
oh we got a plane oh explosions
gotta admit the birds
look
like origami paper
oh man come on
come on come on
oh one kill ah and i'm down
nice that's down
oh headshot nice
so i think we've really found our sweet
spot in terms of settings for the nvidia
rtx 3070 ti
again this is on 4k resolution
at medium quality settings the more i
think about it how about we try 4k at
high settings
we're getting an average about
50 to 60 frames per second come on come
on
that's nice
very clean
to kill looks like it's running pretty
stable
on high i'm very surprised
guys we might have unlocked another
sweet spot
4k on high might just do the trick for
the rtx 3070 ti
it's one
that's two oh oh
oh
oh oh it's getting busy it's getting
busy
there's three
that's four
that's five
let's try and
get that out
boom oh
man i got shot so look guys i think we
can all agree that the rtx 3070 ti has
hit that sweet spot of 60 frames per
second here with 4k resolution and at
high graphics quality
i'd say it's good enough for me man so
look i'm not gonna bore you guys with
any more tests just enjoy this cool
compilation and then we'll head over to
our final thoughts
guys
put your gears up
[Music]
up
put your gears up
[Music]
uh
so is nvidia's rtx 3070 ti capable of
running graphic intensive games well
that is a resounding yes
now i know we've only tested it on
battlefield 2042 but i'm pretty sure it
can run other graphic intensive
aaa games as well now of course the
disclaimer here is that we did kept the
refresh rate at 60 hertz and this is
just to give viewers a glimpse of it
running on a tv or a generic monitor if
you do own a monitor with a higher
refresh rate say 120 hertz or 144 hertz
or even more than that then of course
you will have to step down your graphics
quality settings
just so you can at least hit 60 or
even step it down to 1080p for that
matter if you want to hit 144 of course
this is all dependent on what games
you're going to be playing so you do
have to adjust it accordingly but hey
running 4k at 60 hertz between medium
and high quality settings
still performs so well despite not being
on ultra in fact xeno you play and test
out this right how do you look man oh
dude it looks fantastic exactly
anyway we would like to thank asus and
nvidia for letting us test out this
custom gaming rig and if you'd like to
know more about this setup do check out
the description below if you have any
questions let us know in the comments
below as well and come on guys don't
forget to give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to our channel if you haven't
already
until then this is zacky signing off
you